the Joe Rogan experience yeah I never
had any desire to be a musician at all
zero no bird plays the drum so he's done
of a [ __ ] well I was talking I was
gonna say something about him I finally
did some of that actually stayed on
topic I think he came to my wedding and
then he had to go do a gig and he does
the gig and his wife stayed and he comes
back in a different outfit like a pink
jacket
he left my wedding and it's such a good
friend he came back again because he was
so happy for me because who the [ __ ]
else would want me then my wife and he's
just I was there in Philly at the at the
in Camden at the tweeter center it was
called when we were around the Opie and
Anthony virus tour
so it was Tracy Morgan myself louis c.k
is that the one where Dahmer era got
heckled and he went on and he literally
attacked the crowd
it made Bill burr a legend that was when
Bill I was standing there Liddell fiha I
was standing there I was at under the
[ __ ] monitor right through the
curtain that I was gonna come out I had
the sweet spot you know Bob we'll do it
like 25 minutes in the middle cuz I'm
yeah I was just a [ __ ] so then they put
me there and it was a sweet spot cuz you
take a lot of bullets coming up with a
Philly audience you know in New Jersey
audience and Bill I'd known him but I
had she known him through clubs but I
but he got out there and they were
booing him and he's so [ __ ] awesome
is the way he's made that whole [ __ ]
Boston brilliance and he just started to
pummel them back and said the worst
things you can say every inappropriate
thing you could possibly say calling
talking about their Chi stinks and the
Sixers and just you know thank you
and I watched it I'm like this is
[ __ ] great fun I would [ __ ] the
Liberty Bell exactly 15 minutes he did
yeah and at the end the boos were as
loud as the cheers I think he got a
standing ovation he didn't see it comes
off stays like a fighter he's all sweaty
you see that was [ __ ] horrible what
the [ __ ] was that I went bill that was
great
are you kidding that was [ __ ] amazing
I've never helped and that he still
didn't believe me and then I said you're
gonna remember this this is gonna you
don't know what just happened here if
there's a tape of this this is this is
gonna change you don't even know and I
bring it up to him and he's like he
doesn't want to talk about it but it is
it it was a defining moment for his
everything ya know he's he's that guy
that can just take a moment and rant on
things like he knows how to rant better
than anybody I know in terms of like in
the moment pick things apart and peace
and like he that's what his podcast is
one of the brilliant things about his
podcast he does it two times a week and
it's just him yeah it's just him ranting
which is crazy that he's got that sort
of muscle that he can just rant on
things by himself just starts reading
things and getting pissed off about this
you know what here's what the [ __ ]
problem is and then he just goes off and
what's amazing is he knows what you know
what I what I what I know that you're
not he's not alone he's talking there
yes all of it so he's ranting to people
who love him and he knows they love him
he's comfortable and he loves people
yeah he's one of the sweetest he's a
great guy
[Applause]